ci sono delle volte io per la mente
registro ogni sera ieri sera ho
registrato il video che sarebbe dovuto
uscire oggi e ho detto guarda sono
stanco non voglia di montarlo lo monto
stamattina per farlo uscire poi a pranzo
mi sveglio stamattina e il file video
era corrotto mi ritrovo a dover
registrare questa mattina per far uscire
il video
oggi è la giornata inizia da dio come
sono che non c'è neanche la voglia di
vivere di togliermi il pigiama nel fare
questa cosa direi che possiamo giocare e
ancora non avete sentito la parte
peggiore di tutto questo
[Musica]
mai venuto
sì
[Musica]
ecco
signori questo gioco esattamente ciò che
una persona piena di aspettative si
aspetta di fare quando si alza la
mattina perché ho deciso di rifare
barbie di rimas parti perché mi voglio
male primo è perchè negli ultimi anni
credo sia rimasto in assoluto il
videogioco più bello che esista vero
barbie cosa vuoi farne della tua vita
donna a ok potevo muovermi con le
freccette perfetto non ho capito ogni
volta che lei corre oltre a sembrare che
si stia cadendo addosso orate
l'espressione della faccia che assume un
kring che fa veramente spavento alle
ragazze a questo weekend in realtà
quindi il fidanzato di barbie né chopin
quando ti vedo mi illumini la giornata
anche tu barbie zuccherino mio se
dovesse mai succedermi una cosa del
genere a manetta temi e lasciatemi gli
aerei tu che facevi cagare a suonare la
chitarra mamma mia ragazzi il mio zio
sordo suona meglio
ciao frate ciao ryan invece di fare di
uscire al mancato perché non vai a fare
il pulisci cimiteri mammamia ragazzo ho
sentito guardaroba sembrava parte ancora
si sente quello che strimpella la
chitarra che veramente io la faccio
meglio comunque posso decidere di
mettere i braccialetti a barbie cambiamo
la gonna perfetto youtube.it soccol in
the best way ma in questo gioco
fantastico che cosa adori potrei rifare
gioca bene listino nero con perle si
brevissima fantastico mickey e teresa
hanno fatto bingo
un nuovo videogioco super modelli inter
prima si preme il pulsante camminata da
sempre meglio degli ultimi call of duty
non posso sopportare quel gioco orribile
per due ore quale sarà quello per
spegnere il gioco quello del televisore
magari
mi meraviglio chain un successo blocco
casa dei sogni inattivazione non
attendiamo oltre e che i giochi abbiano
inizio
o sarà uno spasso guarda non ho
assolutamente dubbi
va bene grazie a dio stimi di giochi non
me li ricordo perché sennò mi sarei
rovinato l'adolescenza trovate le scarpe
e nascoste e mettetele sul piedistallo
nell'ordine giusto ma in questo gioco ci
fanno anche i tornei e sport
cioè tu per trovare delle delle scarpe
tocchi le cose va bene perché sia un
picchiando una lampada in tutto questo è
trovato a scarpa perfetto da me la dà
mela e mia brutta soc
sapete neanche mettere le scarpe in
ordine mamma mia che decerebrate a ci
sono tutte
ce l'ha fatta ragazza incredibile e
stata una sfida veramente ai limiti
della mia capacità videoludiche della
casa dei sogni
l'evento di oggi si svolge nella camera
da letto di barbie e sarà una sfida
straordinaria ma non mi dire di scatole
da scarpe devo praha devo prendere più
scarpe come mi stanno battendo come devo
prendere più scarpe possibili ma io sono
un fenomeno in questo pacchetto c'è o
non c'è stato il black friday sono
allenatissimo altro che skyrim
battlefield ragazze in tre secondi non
finisce sto minigioco giuro lancio il
computer sta musica mi sta snervando che
in maniera che non avete idea acquistare
nella tua parte distanza la prossima
volta
la prossima volta giocherà un vero gioco
o gesù veramente il sun mi sta andando
il cervello in pappa in tutto questo se
ho fatto io sono arrivato quasi ultimo e
mi sono pure impegnato e non sto
scherzando la vedo la finale di questo
videogioco commentata con me da me e
guido meda dusk su skyuno garage che non
ha idea di che cosa ci sia in garage
cercate il detergente poi scoprite il
codice mettendo nell'ordine giusto le
bottiglie sui piedistalli mi sono
fermato a detergente proteiforme potrà
essere un detergente se non ti togli
brutta laida
poi gesù ma neanche tom cruise chavasse
cose qua e mission impossible ma che
figata
neanche la cia ho trovato ho trovato la
il detersivo e sessista che sto gioco un
gioco per ragazze si parla di pulizia
che perdiamo tutti quanti insieme
brava social stiamo nel garage per
presentare l'ultima sfida del ministro
ma la cosa che mi fa spavento e che
doppiatori sono anche abbastanza bravi
ce nel senso che sta dentro io faccio
averle pirla
raga queste mini gioco che ha espresso
al meglio le mie capacità videoludiche
negli ultimi anni sei la migliore
proprio come me ma chi cazzo 63
attenzione a 1 sì l'ho presa come ma
cosa come faccio a perdere in gioco per
bambini tre anni sono più impegnati un
sacco maraga non capii veloce ostrava
nella capitale belga è pieno di polli se
sicura che quello sia sapone o perchè
continuate a toccarmi le cose andiamo
via quali erano gli altri mini giochi
che avevo già fatto boh non lo so la
sala trucco sicuramente quindi facciamo
il bagno
trovate i quattro articoli per la
toletta e metteteli sui piedistalli
corretti ma per cani intendi per che
hanno questo il bagno mio non dal cane a
perché sono una cagna ora l'hai trovato
si tratta di roba per cani trovi subito
ea farmi vedere eccoli lì come si
spazzano le 2000 non abbiamo avuto i
risultati migliori per quanto riguarda
la cura degli animali di barbie far
meglio spiega mi cosa clicco aiuto a col
mouse
pulisci noah raga non sono capace io di
pulire i cani e cavalli
i pony qualche mischia 6 raga non vale
letto e sono più e sono più abituati a
stare a quattro zampe io no quindi sanno
come si pulisce un cavallo non posso
perdere tutti i maledetti minigiochi non
posso capitol spazzola come non è mai
spazzolato maledizione vai così che puoi
limonare che è un piacere
yes stavolta
la prendete tutti nel capro anzi tutte
quante in posizione da cavallo adesso
tutte la vera essenza del videogiocatore
moderno è saper affrontare qualsiasi dio
perché finale sono tutte agghindati cani
a un'altra richiesta vuole una pedicure
va bene ragazzi lo so che voi vorreste
vedere la fine di questo videogioco però
le sfide di questo intrepido videogioco
mi hanno sfinito e quindi orgoglioso del
mio lavoro e di come passo in un e di
mattina e non sapete neanche la chicca
di tutto questo non l'avevo mai detto ma
part ii trim aspar costa tipo 35 è uno
dei giochi per il collo speso di più su
steam c'è anche lab della comunità di
barbie dicono sparti cioè dove gli
utenti discutono del gioco e ci sono
immagini come questo è bellissimo io
ragazzi spero che il figlio che sia
piaciuto coma senso che piace momento è
un mi piace anche ai social come
descrizione ricordatevi il fondotinta è
fondamentale fondamentale ragazzi e noi
ci vediamo ad una prossima sfilata a una
prossima pd chirurgia ragazzi ma io devo
montare questa roba
entro un orario decente amo la mia vita
[Musica]